[Music]
TBS we'd work for TBS we do and we love
will yes we still do we love these guys
and of course TBS stands for Turner
Broadcasting System and I've just been
told a very special member of the TBS
family has dropped by to say hello
once again please welcome the founder of
TBS mr. Ted Turner
[Applause]
mr. churner as always we are honored to
have you here shut your mouth you
deformed Ron Howard not fair to either
one of us I founded TBS with one purpose
so people could enjoy Steven Seagal
films without the nudity the way they
were meant to be enjoyed I'll be damned
if I'm gonna sit here and watch my
vision ruined by some sickly wig stand
okay I think zip it open
I see the war on Christmas is a alive
and well in your studio where the hell
are the decorations decorations sir it's
only December 3rd well you might as well
come out here and slap Jesus across the
face it'd be funnier than your monologue
okay now wait that's stepping over the
line Molly Ringwald
the sandier voice makes Teddy jr. here
beg for a trip to Buffalo heaven
okay well of course Teddy jr. is your
stuffed buffalo on wheels oh you take
that back Nancy Teddy jr. is a living
breathing creature a dynamic vibrant
beast at the height of his sexual powers
okay yeah he's raring to go
Wyatt you bulimic pumpkin
I'm here for one reason that d-list
bottom-feeder Will Forte is on the show
tonight Conan I'm not sure if you're
aware but he does a very unflattering
but devastatingly accurate impression
yes mr Turner I'm aware yeah I mean he
has got it down pat the voice the look
the Buffalo I've had surgically attached
between my legs all of it is so
painfully precise
I'm telling you Will Forte might be the
best mimic ever to grace the stage I'm
saying that because I mean it
but that's why Teddy jr. is gonna tear
him limb from limb on your show tonight
right Teddy jr. okay look you're not
you're not going to attack Will Forte
that's not happening okay Will's a nice
guy he's just here to promote his new
movie which is terrific Nebraska all
right
macGruber thinks he's a dramatic actor
now another fantastic decision by a
Hollywood hey remember that guy who
played a drag queen on 30 rock me
neither
all right
well let's put him in a critically
acclaimed movie and Confused a hell at a
every wokai you know what mr. Turner
it's not true when you're making my
audience uncomfortable these all of Fame
bong Wranglers only thing they care
about is snorting powdered rhino horn
while playing candy crush on their
flashlights it's off to snapchat
pictures of themselves masturbating to
duck dynasty doesn't make any sense
Oh Conan if you can watch duck dynasty
without masturbating I'd like to see all
right guys
snap can't be a picture bo not going to
snap - yeah I feel excuse us Teddy jr.
and I are gonna go backstage and have a
little chat with mr. forte if you know
what I mean okay I do not know what you
mean I gotta use my foot to fatten those
already luscious lips you gotta admit
he's one handsome fellow okay same
good-looking guy yes yeah I plan to lay
the boots to him unless I get lost in
his eyes first and if I do knock him out
I don't take a little peek under the
hood my guess briefs and shades oh for
God's sake
[Applause]
for you people be sure to snapchat me a
dick pic from hell